dae-su wrote in saying how would you
deal with the problem of lobbying and
lobbyists this is like a 30,000 foot
issue that really requires a lot of
discussion but I think a couple points
are number one you've got to fix
regulatory capture regulatory capture
where the players in the industry that
is supposed to be regulated end up
controlling the regulator the regulate
or or the agency that is doing the
regulating you've got to deal with that
and more broadly this sort of revolving
door that exists that Donald Trump
initially claimed he wanted to fix but
of course he hasn't if anything he's
pushed it to become an even bigger and
bigger issue in his administration
you've got to deal with that in some way
and I actually think that people
underestimate the impact of campaign
finance on lobbyists and lobbying if you
really had anonymous contributions like
let me give you an example if I believe
that Bernie Sanders is better for the
country and I don't expect anything
personally as a result of donating to
Bernie Sanders I would have no problem
donating anonymously but not anonymously
where the public doesn't know who
donated
I mean anonymously where even the
recipient elected official doesn't know
who don't interesting yeah because if
they don't know who donated it's much
more difficult for them to end up doing
favors and it might disincentivize or
deflate even the desire for lobbyists to
make those contributions it's probably
gonna see a lot fewer contributions
though because if people can't get the
credit for it if companies can't get the
credit for it why would they do it and I
think that that's good and maybe it
would get us going in the direction of
public financing of Elections or
something like that and and it's it's
dicey because you do want to allow
underserved groups to have
representation and then the question is
how do you do it because just because
something is a lobby doesn't mean it's
necessarily good or bad there are lob
you can lobby for something that would
be positive for the whole on the net for
Humanity or negative and and that is a
concern anytime you talk about just
eliminating even the
process by which lobbying takes place
because there are lobbies for very
worthwhile causes I think that the
revolving door is a big deal especially
because I mean we poked fun at Trump's
ban on those who serve in his
administration for five years can't
become lobbyists yeah because I mean
most of the corruptions going on in the
legislative branch right yesterday I
think we have to make it so that if you
serve in Congress if you serve in the
Senate you're banned for life from going
into lobbying and that's a hard thing to
draw because you know this consulting
count does it work the other way around
can the lobbyists become a senator can a
consultant become a congressman I don't
know but I think there's a way forward
on that if there probably is but it is
tricky especially because like you said
ASIC is consulting I think pretty
clearly is lobbying what about being
just a lawyer though right right and
that a lot of times is a way to hide
lobbying efforts and how can you say
somebody who's been a lawyer and then
they served in Congress they're just
going back and being lawyers that's all
you're doing how can you prevent them
from doing that last thing if Congress
increased how much it funds
organizations like the Congressional
Research Service and the GAO the
Government Accountability Office
if those agencies had more funding they
could turn out reports and investigate
more policy issues and part of the
problem is that Congress ends up relying
on reports that are created by lobbyists
to make decisions about policy if you
eliminate their need to do that by
getting better funding for these other
entities you might also kind of remove
the need for lobbyists to say hey we
would like to research X topic for you
and of course the recommendations will
be very very good for our clients if you
enact them I think that that's a small
thing but it also could be could be
useful and positive yeah this is a big
deal when people talk about why they
disapprove of Congress they talk about
the revolving door they talked about
wanting to drain the swamp yeah lobbying
is the heart of the issue it's a big
part of it lobbying and campaign finance
which are connected they're very very
unrelated issues that's it for today we
have got a brilliant bonus show for you
today I hope you'll join us you can sign
up at david pakman.com slash membership
get instant access to the bonus show you
can also make a pledge at patreon.com
slash david pakman show five bucks a
month gets you instant access to the
bonus show which is coming up next